jusqu'au dessus du tunnel de l'alma la
flamme de la liberté a toujours autant
de succès ce n'était pas sa vocation
première
mais la sculpture est subitement devenu
un mémorial dédié à la princesse diana
le temps du souvenir du recueillement et
celui de l' enquête
demain les deux juges d'instruction
convoquons tous les photographes et une
quinzaine de vrais - tous présents au
moment de l'accident
ou juste appelant peut-être vers les
derniers actes d'instruction une enquête
exceptionnelle au lendemain de
l'accident mortel
la presse du monde entier attend conflit
mais les paparazzi arrêtés la nuit même
est mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire et non assistance à
personne en danger
sur le pont de l'allemand une main
anonyme a déjà des idées
les 1 g 75 d'alcool retrouvé dans le
sang dans ripol le chauffeur de la
mercedes suggère une autre lecture du
dossier
mais une partie de l'opinion publique et
des médias anglais ont du mal à s'y
résigner
si médias britanniques qui hier encore
se demander si l'on ne s'était pas
trompé dans les analyses pouvoir si
henri paul n'avait pas été empoisonné
aujourd'hui l'on sait pourtant que ces
dos dit lui-même qui a décidé qu henri
paul conduirait ce soir là ce qui
n'empêche pas son père mohamed al fayed
évoquée régulièrement l'hypothèse de
pompiers le milliardaire égyptien s'est
même payé les services d'un détective
privé pierre ottavioli ancien chef de la
brigade criminelle parce que vous partez
sur une thèse de l'accident est ce que
tout est possible et ce que l'attentât
quelque chose qui peut tenir encore pour
vous pour vous poser une question pour
laquelle à mon avis il est prématuré de
répondre parce que pour répondre à cette
question il faudrait être sûr il ya
accédants ceux qui aiment bien le dire
très vraisemblable mais il faut aussi
éliminer aussi ils étaient perdus
attentats je n'ai pas encore de montrer
les tabloïds anglais mènent aussi leur
enquête
le mirror penser par exemple avoir
retrouvé la voiture qui a été percutée
par la mercedes scoop
ce ne serait pas une fiat uno mais une
ax bien sûr l'information était fausse
car c'est l'une des certitudes de ce
dossier sorti des laboratoires de la
gendarmerie
les débris de phares et les traces de
peinture retrouvée sur la mercedes
proviennent bien d'une fiat uno blanche
la chasse à la petite voiture plus donc
ouverte en région parisienne plus de
2000 fiat où nous ont été contrôlés sans
succès
son boîtier malheureusement un certain
nombre
ce statut de la victime qui seul
explique le caractère exceptionnel des
investigations et la hâte avec laquelle
les photographes on est comme ça je te
pilori demain les neuf photographes et
le motard de presse seront confrontés
aux témoins photographiée ici par des
touristes le 31 août dernier
leur attitude après l'accident sera une
dernière fois examinés il ne manquera
alors plus que l'analyse des composants
électroniques du véhicule et sa vitesse
exacte pour que le dossier soit
semant l'anc est pour l'instant ne parle
que d'un accident de voiture